[Música]
llegó el momento de hablar de economía
en directo américa ya está lista en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela
bienvenida buenos dias usted que está
muerta de frío en esta fría mañana de la
ciudad de bogotá
pero vamos ahora a europa porque podrían
llegar a legislar a favor de los
trabajadores de las plataformas
digitales and all a raúl muy buenos días
usted es el que nunca le da free y nunca
me da frío tengo el termostato
pues mire estas empresas que yo sé que
usted utiliza todo el tiempo se llaman
en las gay que también son conocidas
como las gay y están revolucionando la
economía pero en europa las quieren
poner en cintura hablamos por ejemplo de
uber deliberó entre otras que en países
como españa y reino unido ya deben
tratar a sus domiciliarios como
empleados y no como independientes hay
un borrador de propuesta de la unión
europea conocido por la agencia reuters
que quiere implementar el modelo en
todos los países del bloque comunitario
bueno allí entonces le pregunto qué
implica este modelo de contratación de
estas empresas como delivery porque yo
dije deliberó libra no conocía usted lo
dijo en español exacto bueno pues mire
quienes son considerados empleados
tienen derecho a prestaciones sociales a
vacaciones a incapacidades entre otros
pero también tienen deberes por ejemplo
en muchos casos no pueden trabajar para
otras compañías el documento estima que
unas 15 empresas y hasta 4 millones de
trabajadores podrían quedar incluidos
dentro de esta medida y que los
gobiernos podrían recibir hasta 4 mil
millones de euros anuales en
contribuciones fiscales por parte de
estos trabajadores pero este proceso
apenas se está comenzando la propuesta
debe ser discutida por los estados
miembros y luego pasar al parlamento y
la comisión europea no cree que eso vaya
a pasar antes de 2025 y hablemos de
chilito querido como diría nuestra
compañera a erika olavarría porque la
inflación en ese país sigue presionando
a la economía malas noticias para erika
y para sus familiares que vivan en chile
porque o los chilenos y todos los
chilenos y todas las latinas porque es
un fenómeno que se está viviendo en toda
la región en el caso de chile la tasa de
inflación es del 67 por ciento en los
últimos 12 meses según el instituto de
estadísticas y dos de los productos que
más han subido de precio fueron los es
que hoy están 30 más caros que hace un
año y 1 que a usted le debe gustar el
pan me fascina sí señor y hoy cuesta 7%
más en chile de lo que costaba hace un
año pues está inflación es la mayor
desde 2008 y está muy por encima de lo
que el banco central tiene como meta que
es entre el 2% y el 4% entre los
factores que ayudan a que los precios
suban están los estímulos fiscales que
ha entregado el gobierno y los polémicos
retiros anticipados de pensiones que han
llevado han dado liquidez a la población
recordemos que entre más dinero hay
circulando pues más suben los precios lo
que para mí me provocó un buñuel hito ya
esta comida que se come en colombia en
diciembre sobre todo dani vamos ahora
japón que quieren motivar a las empresas
para que aumenten los sueldos y lo harán
nada más y nada menos que con algo que
les gusta mucho a las empresas que son
las exenciones fiscales por supuesto ya
hay un borrador final del plan anual de
reforma tributaria presentado por el
partido gobernante que debería ser
aprobado a más tardar este viernes este
proyecto dice que aquellas empresas que
no les suben el salario de sus
trabajadores a partir del próximo no
podrán beneficiarse de descuentos
tributarios y las que sí lo hagan van a
tener mayores deducciones esas
deducciones en qué consisten mire las
grandes compañías que suban hasta un 4%
los sueldos van a obtener deducciones de
hasta un 30 por ciento de sus ingresos y
el beneficio será del 40 por ciento para
aquellas empresas pequeñas que aumentan
los salarios en al menos un 2,5 por
ciento y es que lo que pasa en japonés
es que la propia ocde o el club de
países ricos advierte que los salarios
allí se han mantenido prácticamente sin
cambios en los últimos 30 años lo que ha
provocado que japón sufra pues varias
pérdidas y también una gran deflación
que es la deflación lo contrario la
inflación o sea los precios no suben
sino que bajan tenemos que hacer
deflación cuando lleguemos de diciembre
nosotros aquí en el relleno de méxico
dan indicadores los miles se están
suavizando las preocupaciones sobre la
nueva variante del coronavirus y eso ha
ayudado a las bolsas asiáticas que
tuvieron cierres positivos en europa los
inversionistas en alemania
específicamente recibieron al nuevo
canciller con ligeras pérdidas y el
resto de mercados pues operaron mixtos
en los parqués europeos para finalizar
este primer bloque deportivo del día
cifra deportivo económico ya es que
bolivia entrando al estudio y ya piensan
d bueno perdóneme daniela
25% raúl que va a subir el precio del
galón de gasolina en haití a partir de
este viernes ya no va a costar lo
equivalente a 2 dólares en moneda local
sino a 2,5 dólares en junio de 2018 un
anuncio similar va a causó varios días
de manifestaciones violentas y llegaron
incluso a provocar la dimisión del
primer ministro del entonces dan y
gracias por este bloque económico
impecable y deportivo que viene luego
del reportaje el día que ya vamos